Now we're going to apply the
same exercise that we just did.
So here what we did,
we showed that there
is no fundamental difference
between [INAUDIBLE]
and English, which is
[INAUDIBLE] in the history
of Haitian and Creole.
Because what we're doing here,
we are questioning this notion
that Creole formation
is something
which is very
idiosyncratic, which
separates Creoles
from non-Creoles,
in a fundamental sense.
Now what we're
going to do, we're
going to look at the history
of French itself from Latin.
And we're going to ask,
so does that history,
can it be in any way
compared to what happened
in the history of Creole.
In fact, what we
are going to see
is that if we compare Latin
and French, in many ways,
they show that French also
out Creolization Creole.
We're just going to do it very--
In fact, what I'm going to
do now is very tendentious.
But I'm warning you
that it's tendentious.
When I'm comparing
French and Latin
is exactly what
other linguists do
when they compare, say, Haitian
Creole to other languages.
They pick a small
set of patterns
and they say, well, look,
these set of patterns
make Creole really special.
So now I'm picking these
set of patterns I say,
which are very fundamental to
the grammar of any language,
which is the order of words.
So scrambling is
a technical term.
Any of you know German?
Who knows German?
You know German.
OK.
So German has this property
that you can pronounce--
If you say, I don't
know, Mary love pancakes,
you can move things around.
You can say pancakes loves Mary.
NICK: The verb has to be
in the second position.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah.
But the argument
is can move around.
So the verb has a
strict position,
but then arguments
can move around.
It can come first--
and Latin is of the same nature.
Any you has Latin?
Any of you knows Latin?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT 3: It's the
same in Arabic too.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
So many languages
have this capacity
called [INAUDIBLE] Certain
kinds of linguists, like at MIT,
would call it scrambling.
It's like scrambled egg.
You can scramble things around.
So you can have a
sentence, you have
the subject and the object.
And if you have
other things like,
I don't know, like object.
If you say, John
gave a book to Mary,
you have three roles
in that sentence,
the giver, what's
being given, what's
received what's been given.
And things can move
around in this sentence.
They can be scrambled.
Now Latin has that.
You can scramble things around.
Not French.
So cases, like in Latin,
when you say, girl,
it's like [SPEAKING LATIN]
You indicate, like in German--
STUDENT 4: That's because
Latin has and leans heavily
on noun and verb endings.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Exactly.
Exactly.
So those two things
are connected.
Good point.
Good point, Jonathan.
In Latin you have
these endings that
are called case declensions that
tell you whether the noun is
a subject, is an object.
And with that you can move
things around more easily.
Now notice that you have it in
Latin, and in French you don't.
So in French, like
in English, you only
have case marking
like on pronouns.
Like he versus him versus his.
You have that on pronouns but
you don't have it on nouns.
You don't have the
equivalent of he, him, his.
You don't have that on nouns.
But in Latin, any noun
will have to carry
an ending that tells you is
it a subject, is it an object?
It's called case.
So you have overt case.
In Latin, you don't have
articles like "the."
If you learn Latin
you have to learn
that you don't have a "the."
In French you have a "the."
So these are four
basic properties
that you find in Latin that
you don't find in French.
So the point here
is that, well, look,
along these four
major parameters,
French is very
different from Latin.
So if one were to
take the kind of words
that are used to describe
Creole, you would say,
well, French has
broken Latin's grammar.
French has broken Latin.
That's what you
would have to say
because we have four
basic properties of Latin
that somehow French
speakers have
lost as they learned to speak
Latin and create in French.
Now guess what?
If we take those
very same properties
and we compare French
and Haitian Creole,
they are the same.
Canonical order
in both languages.
For pronouns, we have a
difference of pronouns.
But for full nouns you have
the same verb, object order.
Scrambling, French and
Creole, we have the same.
Overt case, the same.
Article, the same.
So what does that show?
That at least along
these four parameters,
Haitian Creole is much
better behaved than French.
In fact, if you were to
create a degree of Creoleness
based on how broken the
grammar is, which is often
what lay people do often.
They think of Creole as Jamaican
Creole is broken English.
Haitian Creole is broken French.
So here, you would
have to say then
that French is broken Latin.
Actually, there is a very
well-known historical linguist
called Antoine Meillet.
Antione Meillet
was aware of that.
actually wrote something
which I find very striking.
He said that if we compare the
Romance languages, not only
French, but Spanish, Italian,
Portuguese, Romanian,
so they are called
the Romance languages.
Actually, I often
hear people say
they are romantic languages.
They can be romantic, but
the technical term is they
are Romance, Romance languages.
So those Romance languages,
they have structures that are--
actually, he used the
term "fundamentally
different from their
Latin counterparts."
So linguists, very smart
linguists, are aware of that.
And even say that, this is
still Meillet, "All this makes,"
he called it, "neo-Latin
languages fall
into a typological class
that is quite remote from
the structural type of Latin."
And that's very clear, right?
I couldn't be any clearer.
So which means that this notion
of Creole languages having
broken the syntax of
their European ancestors
is very tendentious because
[INAUDIBLE] linguists
realized that all
languages evolve
through these
structural breaks, even
those that are often presented
as prototypical genetic
languages.
Meaning that,
languages with parents.
Go ahead, Nick.
NICK: Were the
Gaulish languages,
did they have those features
that neo-Latin language?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's
a very good question.
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah, I don't
know about Gaulish language.
That's what you are
going to find out.
So how did French
develop those patterns?
Is it from the
substrate languages,
which is like the Gaulish?
That's a very good question.
Yeah, that's exactly what
you would want to ask.
Because we know, and in the case
of Haitian Creole, not all--
and I want to stress, not all--
but many of the features
of Haitian Creole
were inherited from
the African substrates.
For example, the fact
that you have the article
after the noun not
before the noun,
that's straight out
from the Gbe languages,
which have the same pattern.
So there's a common thread
here in the argument.
Those breaks that you see in
the history of Creole languages,
you also find them
in the history
of non-Creole languages.
JOSE: Is Afrikaans a Creole?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's
a very good point.
So there was one linguist
who some time ago called
Afrikaans a Creole language.
And he got into big trouble
because the Afrikaans
speak-- is very upset.
JOSE: It's like a Creole,
but for Dutch people.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right.
Exactly.
So the Afrikaaners
were upset that they
dared compared the Afrikaans
language to Creole.
Because for them, Afrikaans
was a variety of Dutch
and it should not be
never called Creole.
STUDENT 4: What year was that?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Oh, that
was in the early '80s,
I think, early '80s.
But that was a very live
discussion, in fact.
At some point there was a
linguist who had to step back
and say, well, OK,
Afrikaans isn't a Creole,
it's a semi-Creole.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSE: So I guess
that's [INAUDIBLE]
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Yeah, definitely.
So what I have to add, that
linguist, actually, his name
is John Holm, the late
John Holm, I asked him,
how do you measure
semi-Creoleness?
How many features must you
have to be a semi-Creole?
Which goes back
to that question,
can you define Creoleness based
on a set of features, which
is very problematic, actually.